the Dawson's Creek gang might have said
goodbye to capeside and complicated
self-aware convos long ago but they're
still around and for a few all you have
to do to see them is flip on the
Hallmark Channel it's impossible to
separate Dawson's Creek from actor James
vanderbeek who played Dawson lery and
instantly shot to stardom vanderbeek has
always seemed comfortable in the
spotlight and his self-deprecating sense
of humor continues to win fans over what
is with this when Harry m80s crap does
apply to us we transcend it after the
series premiere young heartthrob
vanderbeek landed major roles in films
like Varsity Blues and the rules of
attraction he still occasionally pops up
in films but these days it's in
memorable bit Parts instead of starring
roles vanderbeek has also appeared on
television in recent years he played Dr
Joe Briggs on the short-lived NBC drama
mercy and a self-centered Sad Sack
version of himself and don't trust the
bee in apartment 23 yeah but isn't this
going to hurt me on Dancing With the
Stars he had a lead role on CSI cyber
which lasted for just two seasons more
recently you might have seen him on pose
or heard him as the voice of Boris on
Disney's vampirina vanderbeek made
headlines in 2023 for a Tik Tok rant
calling for US President Joe Biden to
take the debate stage ahead of his
reelection campaign in addition to
playing Joey on Dawson's Creek Katie
Holmes appeared in the notable films go
Disturbing Behavior and teaching Mrs
tingle in which she co-starred with
Helen mirin Holmes has had a solid
acting career since but she's probably
better known for her personal life at
this point who was the best kisser on
Dawson's
Creek to be
for yeah come on da ping things looked
pretty promising for Holmes after
Dawson's Creek ended she was cast as
Rachel Daws in Batman Begins and had a
small role in Thank You for Smoking then
she met Tom Cruz and just 7 weeks later
they were engaged given his status in
Hollywood and Holmes as a rising star in
the industry the pair held it coupes
status for much of their marriage but
when they divorced in 2012 it seemed to
affect Holmes's career that career seems
to have recovered in later years with
Holmes playing Jackie Kennedy in the
miniseries the kennedies and Paige Finny
in a memorable arc on Ray Donovan more
recently she starred in the horror flick
Brahms The Boy 2 the actor has been
focusing on her work behind the camera
in recent years directing and producing
on the kennedies as well as feature
films all we had alone together and rare
objects everyone thinks of Dawson and
Joey when they remember Dawson's Creek
but we can't forget Jen played by
Michelle Williams Jen starts out as a
complete mess who's been sent to
capeside to live with her grandmother
her upbringing differs from the other
lead characters which gives her a unique
perspective on life in the town now
Jenny Jen okay it's Jen Williams has a
formidable range as an actor she's been
nominated for Academy Awards on five
separate occasions but has yet to win
she was nominated for best supporting
actress for Brokeback Mountain and
Manchester by the Sea and leading
actress for 2010's Blue Valentine and
2011's My Week with Marilyn Williams
most recent Oscar nod came in 2023 when
she played The Tragically Whimsical
mother in Steven Spielberg's pseudo
biopic the fabl mens you do what your
heart says you have
to you don't ow anyone your life
Williams will probably score another
Oscar nom for her star turn as singer
Peggy Lee in the biopic fever some of
her more recent roles include Anne
weighing in venom and its sequel charity
Barnum in the greatest showman and Gwyn
verden in the miniseries fossy verden
for which she won her first Emmy Award
on Dawson's Creek pacy played by Joshua
Jackson rounds out the four most
prominent characters on the show Well
Jack tells me you're
dying but other than that everything's
okay right Jackson has continued to find
success in the post Dawson years a few
years after the series finale Jackson
landed a starring role in the Sci-Fi
series Fringe Fringe ran until 2013 when
he landed yet another major role on the
Showtime series The Affair Jackson has
also had success as a stage actor and
appeared in a few major miniseries look
for him on Hulu's little fires
everywhere as the husband of ree
Witherspoon Elena on Dr Death alongside
Alec Baldwin Christian Slater and Carrie
Preston and on the critically panned but
audience adored adaptation of Fatal
Attraction on Paramount plus even though
Dawson's Creek was buil as a teen drama
most of the Supporting Cast was old as
parents and other authority figures were
Central to the show's Story actor Mary
Beth Peele is one of the most memorable
playing Jen's religious grandmother
Evelyn Grahams Ryan Peele was a renowned
stage actor before being cast as Grahams
earning a Tony Award nomination for her
role in a 1985 run of The King and I
she's returned to the stage often since
then receiving yet another Tony
nomination in 2017 for her role in
Anastasia as one of my favorite artists
Eminem once said you you better lose
yourself in the music the moment you own
it you better never let it go on the
film and television side of things peels
appeared in major films like 2006's
Flags of Our Fathers and 2008's mirrors
her biggest television role since
Dawson's Creek came in The Good Wife
where she played Peter's mother Jackie
even though actor Kerr Smith didn't show
up until season 2 of Dawson's Creek his
character was Central for the remainder
of the show's run Smith played Jack a
rebound love interest for Joey before
becoming popular enough to Warrant his
own storyline remember back then a lot
of the fan mail that I was getting were
from kids that
were teenagers in the closet and they
were kind of going through the exact
same experience as what we were telling
Smith has carved out quite a career for
himself between his many recurring
television roles and a handful of lead
performances he hasn't worked much in
films since early in his career when he
appeared in a number of horror movies
including Final Destination on the TV
side however Smith has been all over the
place after Dawson's Creek in did Smith
landed major roles on the legal drama
Justice and the military drama e-ring
unfortunately neither series made it
past its first season Smith also
appeared briefly on NCIS he had a little
more luck with the Fosters and Life
Unexpected more recently you may have
caught Smith on the absolutely banana
show Riverdale where he plays principal
Holden honey throughout the show's run
Dawson's parents go through almost as
much drama as he and his friends do
Dawson's mother Gail was played by actor
Mary Margaret Humes and her on again off
again marriage to husband Mitch showed
that relationship hurdles never stop no
matter how old you are Humes began as a
model in 1975 as Miss Florida she was
third runner up in the missusa pageant
she started making guest appearances on
TV not long after and appeared in films
like history of the World Part One and
the series Eerie Indiana since Dawson's
Creek came to an end Humes occasionally
makes TV guest appearances but her bread
and butter gig seems to be Hallmark
Channel movies including winter her love
story a Valentine's match and Christmas
in love Dawson's father played by
veteran actor John Wesley ship has
enough charm old school good looks and
dark secrets to make him every bit as
compelling and memorable as the younger
characters but the
chance of actually
winning that's something I could really
use right now after Dawson's Creek he
had recurring roles on Teen Wolf and One
Life to Live ship is probably best known
for his recent work on the arrowe shows
on the CW he first appeared on the flash
as Henry Allen and has since made
appearances on other Series in crossover
episodes It's a role he fits into very
nicely ship actually played Barry Allen
AKA The Flash on the shli series all the
way back in
1990 another important Dawson's Creek
character who didn't show up until the
second season is Andy sister to Jack MC
played by actor Meredith Monroe Andy is
innocent and enthusiastic by Nature even
in the face of extreme hardship you get
behind by one day and then you're always
struggling to catch up and then you just
get more and more confused and then the
next thing you know you're out on the
street drunk and dirty Wheeling a
shopping cart over the years since
Dawson's Creek came to an end Meredith
Monroe has carved out an impressive
career she occasionally lands recurring
roles but you've most likely seen her in
a single episode guest star appearance
on series like the closer NCIS The
Mentalist and Bones if you're looking
for some of Monroe's more substantial
roles check her out as Haley hotner from
Criminal Minds her run on that show
ended in 2013 more recently she appeared
in the film The Edge of 17 and she also
had a substantial role on 13 Reasons Why
actor bzy Phillips joined the Dawson's
Creek party pretty late her character
Audrey Liddell didn't show up until the
show's Fifth Season still she became a
central character over the show's final
two seasons as Joey's friend and college
roommate by the time she appeared on
Dawson's Creek she'd already picked up
some name recognition from the
critically acclaimed series Freaks and
Geeks Phillips's had an impressive
career in the years since Dawson's Creek
the role she's probably best known for
these days is Lori Keller on Cougar Town
but she's also had recurring roles on
shows like er and vice principles as
well as one-off appearances on hit shows
like search party new girl and Arrested
Development Phillips has appeared in a
number of films often in smaller
supporting roles look for her in White
Chicks Made of Honor the gift and I feel
pretty she also hosted the E talk show
busy tonight from 2018 to 2019 I'm a
memorize this I'm
memorizing all of it Phillips has used
her celebrity to address social issues
that are meaningful to her she's a major
advocate for abortion rights and started
the hashtag you know me to encourage
women to share their stories and help
eliminate the stigma of abortions she
shared publicly that she had an abortion
at age 15 and has helped to raise
awareness and fight against state laws
that restrict the procedure perhaps
better known as douge or Deputy dog pacy
witters an annoyingly straight-laced Big
Brother Doug appeared in just 20
episodes over Dawson's Creek's Prime
Time run however few characters
maximized their screen time as much as
Dylan Neil Neil perfectly embodied the
self-righteousness of an older sibling
who also played the part of a pseudo
Father Figure in his younger brother's
life as being the leading Contender for
the official joke of capeside bother you
even a little bit because I must say
it's a distinction the rest of the
Witter family could certainly live
without the actor has however spent much
of his postc Creek career spreading his
charm on the small screen he started out
playing Sabrina spelman's almost husband
on Sabrina the Teenage Witch and over
the years Neil has appeared in hit
series like Psych the LW Smallville and
Bones among others though Arrow fans no
doubt recognize him as Dr Anthony Ivo in
recent years Neil has also become a
regular player on the Hallmark Channel a
turn that began with a starring role
opposite Andy McDow in the drama series
Cedar Cove Neil has appeared in several
Hallmark projects since including five
episodes of The Gourmet detective which
he co-created for the network alongside
his wife Becky southwell and Christmas
she wrote which he starred in alongside
Danica mckel it hardly seems like it but
pacy wht's big sis Gretchen logged just
as many episodes as Big Brother Doug
that's in part because her Dawson's
Creek sent began and ended in season 4
despite the One season and done Arc
Sasha Alexander shined in the role and
more than left her mark on the series
you know I'm the only one here with the
right to feel like a freak
my senior prom was last century you know
when you think about it it's actually
kind of depressing Dawson's Creek was
Alexander's first real break in
Hollywood though she had fronted Creek
Creator Kevin Williamson's short-lived
series Wasteland before playing Gretchen
Witter in the Years following her series
exit Alexander made notable appearances
in major films like Mission Impossible 3
Yes Man and He's Just Not That Into You
and the actor booked one of the biggest
roles of her career in the immediate
aftermath of Dawson's Creek signing on
to play NCIS regular Caitlyn Todd in
2003 in 2010 Alexander became the star
of her very own series fronting rosoli
and Isles alongside Angie Harmon for
seven full seasons Shameless fans will
also surely recall her as Helen runan of
all the stars who got their start on
Dawson's Creek few shined brighter in
the immediate aftermath of their
departure than Michael pit pit joined
the Dawson's Creek cast in season 3 as
Henry Parker a tender-hearted freshman
football player Who develops a seriously
intense Rush on Michelle Williams Jen
Lindley you don't even make eye contact
with me in the hallway it's like you got
this giant blind spot and exactly my
shape and science though the pair
eventually coupled up their romance
ended for good when season 3 did likely
because pit was fast becoming the toast
of the indie film scene in fact pit
quickly scored major roles in memorable
films like finding Forester bully hewig
and the Angry Inch and the dreamers he
then went on to share the screen with
Ryan goling and Sandra bulock in the
underrated Thriller Murder By number
members booked a minor role in ight
shyamalan's the village and terrorized
Naomi Watts in the US remake of funny
games we going to make a bet now you bet
that you'll be alive tomorrow at 9:00
and we bet that you'll be dead in 2010
Martin scors sessi tapped pit to play
Jimmy Dary in his star studded gangster
drama series Boardwalk Empire which pit
followed with a deeply unsettling turn
as Mason Verger on Hannibal
unfortunately the actor has struggled
both legally and emotionally of late
though he's looking to make a big screen
comeback with a role in the hotly
anticipated biod drama you can't win
it's almost shocking to realize how
little time Monica Kina actually spent
playing Troublemaker Abby Morgan on the
set of Dawson's Creek you're turning me
into a juvenile delinquent the series OG
mean girl didn't even make it out of the
second season as it was Kina shared most
of her scenes with Michelle Williams as
Abby fanned the simmering bad girl
Flames within Jen Lindley before her
shocking season 2 death as Kevin
Williamson recently explained aby's
death was very much of Ken's making but
the actor did pretty well for herself
after leaving Dawson's Creek behind
promptly booking roles in teen Centric
Fair like crime and punishment in
Suburbia and the Jack Black cult comedy
Orange County she went on to play a key
role in Jud appat house canceled too
soon College dramedy Undeclared she
followed up with recurring roles on
Entourage Grace's Anatomy private
practice and Castle Kina has worked less
frequently since 2013 when personal
struggles with her troubled EX Edward
Furlong landed her on tabloid covers but
the actor has rebounded of late and
appears to have a handful of intriguing
projects in the works like many of his
Dawson's Creek co-stars Jensen Ackles
didn't have many screen credits before
he joined the series cast he had however
worked for years on Days of Our Lives
and shared the screen with Jessica Alba
in James Cameron's sci-fi series Dark
Angel needless to say he was hardly a
noob when he signed up to play Bay
College helpline hunk CJ Braxton in
Cesar 6 Ackles no doubt needed to
leverage those years of experience as he
regularly shared the screen with more
seasoned Creek stars like Michelle
Williams and Kur Smith a look at
ackles's postc Creek credits confirms
that the show served as a professional
springboard the actor soon signed up to
play football coach turned villain Jason
Teague in season 4 of Smallville M
girlin invites me to some old for
some brass rubbing I I thought it was
code for something else he followed that
gig with a celebrated run as Dean
Winchester on the iconic fantasy series
Supernatural akles would of course play
that role for 15 Seasons before it
finally left the airwaves most recently
Ackles joined the cast of the hit
superhero satire the boys if you've seen
him as old school soup Soldier Boy on
the show you know the role Rivals his
work on
Supernatural with the capeside gang
going co-ed for seasons 5 and six of
Dawson's Creek an influx of new faces
made their way into the mix the new cast
members included Oliver Hudson who
turned up as Eddie Doling the
literary-minded bow of Katie Holmes Joey
we're regular Sam and Diane me with my
rugged charms you with your fancy book
learning though fans may have tired a
bit of their on again off again romance
few could argue Hudson didn't bring some
serious intellectual and emotional heat
to the proceedings Hudson is part of a
Hollywood brood that includes Bill
Hudson Goldy H Kurt Russell Kate Hudson
and Wyatt Russell so acting is in his
DNA while Dawson's Creek was one of his
biggest early roles it was hardly his
last Hudson would go on to appear in the
2006 remake of black Christmas and land
a recurring role on the long-running
sitcom Rules of Engagement starring
alongside Patrick warber Burton and
David Spade the actor would follow that
with a three-season run as record exec
Jeff foram on Nashville and score a
steady gig on Ryan Murphy's scream
Queens in 2018 he starred with stepdad
Kurt Russell in the Christmas Chronicles
most recently Hudson appeared in the Sex
in the City sequel and just like that by
the time Ken Marino made his way to
capeside he'd already made a bit of a
name for himself in Hollywood circles
having appeared on numerous hit sitcoms
in the 9s he also earned fans for his
work on the sketch comedy series the
state and the cult comedy sensation Wet
Hot American Summer given his largely
comedic background it was a bit of a
surprise that his Dawson's Creek role as
Professor David Wilder was a touch more
serious in fact Marino showed unexpected
range as the Charming English teacher
who briefly wooed the lit loving Joey
Potter you are obviously right
there which means the torture has just
begun Marino has continued to show that
range in dozens of projects over the
years if you've been tracking his career
you know these projects are too numerous
to even consider covering in detail
nevertheless it's safe to say that one
of Marino's more baffling post Creek
gigs came in 2009 when he reprised the
role of David Wilder in an episode of
Californication Hank Moody David Wilder
big fan big big fan among the actor's
more legit highlights however would have
to be his recurring role as sleazy
private detective Vinnie Van low on
Veronica Mars and his iconic turn as Ron
Donald in the Beloved service and
entertainment industry Insider comedy
party
down